some great things about watching a  musical performance and IMAX's is the  reality that we can bring to the sound  these sounds these frequencies these  continuous levels high levels low end  and rip in the guitar the mid-range and  spiky guitar we understood that we had  to rebalance for certain formats  one of the most important aspects in an  IMAX sound system is the dynamic range  with the wide dynamic range you can feel  music people enjoy  we found this extra girth that we took  advantage of and it became one of our  favorite floor mounts especially with  the directional concert surround  speakers that just was just very  powerful you have two full range  speakers about there pounding away at  you and they're pretty discreet sounding  this raw